vice president pence is criticizing
supreme court justice chief justice john
roberts tonight correspondent kristen
fisher tells us
why chief justice john roberts has been
a disappointment to conservatives
vice president mike pence venting his
frustration with chief justice john
roberts
for siding with the supreme court's
liberal justices in a string of recent
defeats
for the trump administration from
upholding the daca program for
undocumented immigrants
to extending protections to lgbtq
workers
the chief justice also ruled against a
church in nevada
fighting for more than 50 people to
attend services in the middle of the
pandemic
and he struck down a louisiana law
requiring abortion providers
to have admitting privileges at local
hospitals
i think it's been a wake-up call for
pro-life voters around the country who
understand
in a very real sense the destiny of the
supreme court is on the ballot
in 2020. so far the chief justice has
not responded to the vice president's
criticism
nor did he react when president trump
called his 2012 decision to uphold
obamacare
disgraceful but in 2018 roberts did
issue a rare rebuke after president
trump
referred to a federal judge as an obama
judge roberts wrote in part quote
we do not have obama judges or trump
judges bush judges or clinton judges
that independent judiciary is something
we should all be thankful for
people need to know that we're not doing
politics they need to know that we're
doing something different
that we're applying the law this term
roberts solidified his role as the
court's anchor justice
by siding with the majority in 58 of 60
cases
that's more than any other justice he
has a history of being a very
impartial fair almost umpire-like
justice who calls them as he sees them
but the president puts
loyalty to conservatism at the top of
the list when considering new judicial
appointees
he's already gotten 200 confirmed that's
a record
for a first-term president and just like
he did in 2016
he's now promising to release a new list
of potential nominees to the supreme
court
if he secures a second term mike kristin
fischer at the supreme court
thanks very much